what is that all for the colors what's
this for what are those for it this is
certainly not the no makeup makeup look
this this is a lot of makeup I would go
so far as I said this is the opposite of
no makeup I think if you want to do it
you want to wear makeup to look like
you're not wearing makeup like it's 2016
do it makeup remover wipes so the only
thing you should need for no makeup book
I'll do break that yeah like it's not
excellent I think I'm a crash and burn
but I mean I'm already done right no
makeup Oh probably took me ten minutes
to recreate the lunge is gonna go for it
it's a nice presentation I don't I'm
just gonna use like maybe one item
I'm so shiny
how did this happen this is devastating
do you have to make that noise yes apply
foundation what what is foundation and
they're like a specialty like size we're
supposed to use and we just do the big
one cuz you got a big face creamy beige
it might be beige what is my skin tone
clear that looks like powder to set
everything as you are you just kind of
like put the lid on yeah do that okay oh
no this is terrible I gotta start over
you like a makeup is just the grossest
thing in the world it's just a bunch of
like mud Youth concealer on under head
and any blemishes what we are what we
are know is what does conceal it see
isn't this fun aren't you having fun
optional step bake your face because I
mean optional I don't I just an option I
don't take things that's good bronze
perimeters of face some looks like the
surface of Mars you're supposing eyes I
can say like girls do this for hours how
many more minutes do we have it's all of
my shirt
they look they filled in highlight
cheekbones what better to highlight wit
then yellow oh yeah maybe he was born
with it
[Music]
well out voila we're beautiful this
looks terrible
I think I had an issue with all 14 steps
I understand why a lot of women might
want to just wear makeup to kind of hide
certain things that you don't like me
might as well have no makeup on you
don't need it you don't need it
so if you want to wear makeup for the no
makeup let's do it well you just like
applying a makeup on don't even try it
[Music]